Hal sto jetzt reicht
es love Island Prince Charming
Temptation Island Trash TV spaltet die
Nation die einen lieben es und die
anderen hassen es trotzdem oder
vielleicht auch genau deshalb ist
reality TV super erfolgreich 2021 machte
der Anteil von reality TV sogar
teilweise über 40% aus was aber wenn
diese Sendungen ein millionenpuikum
dümmer machen das behaupten super viele
Artikel und erklärt Gegner von Trash TV
angeblich steckt da sogar eine echte
Wissenschaft hinter und genau hier sind
wir misstrauisch geworden wir haben uns
diese Studien zu Trash TV für euch mal
genauer angeschaut und so viel kann man
schon mal sagen heute geht es um
schlechten
Journalismus wenn wir Trash TV sagen
dann meinen wir meistens reality TV und
reality TV bedeutet gewöhnlich wirkende
Menschen in ganz alltäglich aussehenden
Situationen dabei sollen die K Daten
sehr authentisch rüberkommen und die
Handlungen wirken alle recht spontan
außerdem werden konventionelle
Erzählstrukturen gebrochen da gerade das
Unvorhersehbare die Zuschauer so fesselt
und das kann natürlich Spaß machen wir
Menschen schnüffeln eben gerne in der
Privatsphäre anderer Menschen herum und
reality TV bietet genau das man könnte
diese Formate also einfach unter die
Kategorie Unterhaltung stecken und das
ganze nicht zu ernst nehmen aber dann
Geistern eben doch solche Meldungen
durch die Medien Dschungelcamp love und
Co macht Trash TV dumm Forscher
bestätigt Trash TV lässt hirnchrumpfen
und Wissenschaftler weisen nach dass
viel Trash TV dem Gehirn schadet
schrecklich aber stimmt das überhaupt
wir haben uns einmal durch all diese
Artikel gegraben und etwas Spannendes
gefunden sie haben alle voneinander
abgeschrieben eine bedeutende Mehrheit
der Artikel bezieht sich auf eine Studie
von Ryan J dorityy der ist Professor für
Neurologie an einer Hochschule für
öffentliche Gesundheit cool klingt ja
erstmal nach guter Wissenschaft und auch
nach gutem Journalismus aber ich würde
gutes Geld darauf wetten dass kein
einziger dieser Journalisten jemals die
Studie selber gelesen hat aber bevor wir
uns die Studie mal etwas genauer
anschauen was bedeutet es eigentlich
dumm zu werden und lässt sich das
überhaupt messen gemessen wird Dummheit
ironischerweise meist über Intelligenz
aber hier liegt auch schon ein großes
Problem auch wenn es oft so angenommen
wird streng genommen ist Dummheit nicht
das Gegenteil von Intelligenz auch
intelligente Menschen können sich dumm
Verhalten oder sind in einzelnen
Entscheidungen dumm dumm ist der der
Dummes tut darüber haben wir übrigens
ein ganzes Video gemacht warum schlaue
Menschen dumme Dinge sagen oder der
nobelpreisfluch und ein anderes Problem
es gibt gar keine einheitliche
Definition von Intelligenz da es ein von
der Gesellschaft erschaffenes Konzept
ist die meisten Psychologen halten sich
an die Definition dass Intelligenz die
Fähigkeit ist aus Erfahrung zu lernen
Probleme zu lösen und sich an neue
Situationen anzupassen in der
Wissenschaft sind aber noch viele Fragen
in Bezug zur Intelligenz offen z.B ob er
sich bei der Intelligenz um eine
gesamtfähigkeit handelt oder um viele
einzelne Fähigkeiten und ob man
Intelligenz im Gehirn überhaupt
lokalisieren kann auch das ist noch
komplett offen eines ist jedoch sicher
Intelligenz ist eine Kombination aus
genetischen Veranlagungen und
Umweltfaktoren das heißt wie schlau wir
sind kann auch durch äußere Faktoren wie
Bildung Erfahrung und Training
beeinflusst werden und das kann
vielleicht auch Trash TV einschließen
trotzdem ist es sehr schwierig
Intelligenz richtig zu messen dafür gibt
es bislang hauptsächlich zwei
verschiedene Wege erstens können wir
Intelligenztests verwenden der wohl
bekannteste von ihnen ist der iqtest und
zum anderen lässt sich Intelligenz über
Gehirnstrukturen bestimmen z.B über den
Anteil von grauer Hirnsubstanz je höher
die Menge an grauer Substanz in
bestimmten Hirnregionen und je mehr
Synapsen dort ausgebildet sind desto
intelligenter soll ein Mensch sein doch
beide Wege haben ihre Vor und Nachteile
und generell ist die Messung von
Intelligenz einfach sehr komplex alleine
z.B unterschiedliche kulturelle
Prägungen gerecht zu berücksichtigen ist
ganz schön knifflig so knifflig dass es
ein eigenes Video werden könnte und wenn
euch das interessiert schreibt mir das
gerne mal unten in die Kommentare aber
kommen wir nun zu der eigentlichen
Studie wird man durch Trash TV nun
dümmer die kurze Antwort wir wissen es
nicht denn darum ging es in der Studie
gar nicht kein Scherz in der Studie ging
es eigentlich zum einen ganz generell um
den Fernsehkonsum und das ganz
unabhängig vom Inhalt und zum anderen
ging es um die Auswirkung davon auf die
allgemeine gehirngesundheit nicht
explizit Intelligenz gehirngesundheit
wurde hier unter anderem im Zusammenhang
mit späteren Alzheimer oder
Demenzerkrankungen in Verbindung
gebracht okay okay okay aber fangen wir
mal von vorne an das eigentliche Ziel
der Studie war es herauszufinden ob die
Effekte vom Fernsehgucken auf das Gehirn
nur darauf zurückzuführen sind dass wir
dabei sitzen oder ob das Fernsehgucken
selber zusätzlich negative Effekte
hervorruft dass Bewegung generell immer
besser ist als nichts tun das ist nichts
Neues aber ob es einen Unterschied macht
welche Art der sitzenden Tätigkeiten wir
dabei ausüben das ist eben noch nicht
ganz klar und genau das wollte die
Studie herausfinden also um das mal eben
festzuhalten es geht in der viel
zitierten Studie weder um TV noch um
Intelligenz und eigentlich auch ziemlich
viel ums sitzen dafür wurden in einem
Zeitraum von 20 Jahren die Entwicklung
der grauen Gehirnsubstanz beobachtet die
tägliche fernsehdauer notiert sowie die
sonstigen körperlichen Tätigkeiten
erfasst und tatsächlich die Ergebnisse
deuten darauf hin dass der Fernsehkonsum
selbst eine Rolle für die Gesundheit des
Gehirns spielt ein hoher Fernsehkonsum
über die 20 Jahre in Weg hat das Volumen
der grauen Gehirnsubstanz von den
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern
tatsächlich verringert und dieser Effekt
konnte auch nicht durch sonstige
körperliche Aktivität aufgehoben werden
also noch mal zusammengefasst
Fernsehkonsum spielt unabhängig davon
dass es eine sitzende Tätigkeit ist eine
Rolle für die Gesundheit des Gehirns und
zu dem Schluss sind auch andere Studien
gekommen die haben wir euch wie immer
ganz transparent in der
Videobeschreibung zusammen mit allen
anderen Quellen verlinkt hatte Mama
damals also vielleicht doch Recht mit
ihrem zu lange Fernseh schauen macht
dumm ja aber hier ist es wichtig zu
betonen die Studie spricht von einem zu
langen fern Konsum und damit sind vor
allem mehr als dreieinhalb Stunden
täglich über einen langen Zeitraum
gemeint und Fernsehschauen bleibt dabei
nur einer von vielen Faktoren der die
gehirngesundheit bestimmt auch
körperliche Aktivitäten Alter und das
generelle Bildungsniveau Spielen für die
Gesundheit des Gehirns eine Rolle die
Studie rund um Ryan J dority räumt
selber ein dass es noch weitere
zusätzliche Gewohnheiten gibt die mit
dem Fernsehkonsum einhergehen können wie
Ernährung Schlaf und soziale Faktoren
die sie in der stud jedoch gar nicht
kontrollieren konnten außerdem steht bei
all den Studien auch wieder das huh ei
was war zuerst da Problem im Raum eine
Studie hat zumindest im Zusammenhang mit
aggressivem Verhalten und TV-Konsum die
Theorie aufgestellt dass nicht unbedingt
Fernsehgucken aggressiv macht sondern
eventuell aggressive Personen einfach
mehr Fernseh gucken um das sicher sagen
zu können braucht es aber einfach noch
mehr
[Musik]
Studien okay aber wie kam es denn dann
zu den Headlines dass Trash TV dumm
macht wenn das doch gar nicht in der
Studie gesagt wird die traurige aber
simple Antwort schlechter Journalismus
in diesem konkreten Fall lief das ganze
so ab der allererste Artikel den wir
finden konnten hat die Studie noch
korrekt zitiert the proof is in TV
really does rot your brain allerdings
hat der Journalist auch seine eigene
Meinung in den Bericht mit einfließen
lassen was an sich nicht dramatisch wäre
da er selbst leidenschaftlicher Filme
und serienucker ist und das sogar
täglich und ausgiebig tut wollte er die
Ergebnisse scheinbar nicht so ganz
wahrhen deswegen hat er die Ergebnisse
an seine Ansichten angepasst und das ist
natürlich nicht okay so kam er zu dem
Schluss dass vermutlich nur schlechte
Inhalte negative Auswirkungen auf das
Gehirn haben also Trash TV und da er
selber solche Inhalte nicht schaut muss
er sich ja glücklicherweise wohl doch
keine Sorgen machen auch wenn das gar
nicht die Aussage der Studie war aber
immerhin war bei ihm noch relativ gut zu
erkennen was hier Studieninhalt und was
Meinung ist leider griffen spätere
Journalisten dann hauptsächlich nur die
persönliche Meinung auf und
präsentierten sie in ihren Artikeln wie
das offizielle Ergebnis der Studie
herauskam dann Forscher bestätigt Trash
TV lässt
hirnschrumpfen und dass das alles so
passiert ist zeigt sich nicht nur daran
dass die anderen Artikel später
veröffentlicht wurden sondern vor allem
daran dass die anderen Journalisten den
ersten Artikel als Quelle verlinkt haben
leider sind solche Headlines nicht
selten euch allen sind wahrscheinlich
auch schon schlagzahen wie diese hier
über den Weg gelaufen jeden Tag ein Glas
Wein trinken ist gesund ältere
Geschwister sind die schlechteren
Autofahrer orios wirken wie Heroin oder
auch die immer wieder falsch
wiedergegebene schwedenstudie die gesagt
haben soll dass E-Autos ihren CO2
Fußabdruck erst nach 8 Jahren wieder
einholen all diese Aussagen die sich
nach einem kurzen Faktencheck als
wissenschaftlich nicht haltbar
herausstellen und nun in der Welt
kursieren haben Journalistinnen und
Journalisten verbockt wissentlich oder
nicht und teilweise gibt es hinter
solchen vermeintlich wissenschaftlichen
Aussagen noch nicht einmal eine
wissenschaftliche Quelle manche Fakten
entstehen durch reine Marketingzwecke
Sowi bei dem Fakt dass man 10 000
Schritte am Tag gehen soll das war eine
reine Verkaufsstrategie einer
japanischen Firma die Schrittzähler
verkaufen wollte und weil diese damals
nur maximal 10 000 Schritte erfassen
konnten könnt ihr euch vermutlich denken
auf welchen genialen kniff die
Werbeagentur gekommen sein muss und
trotzdem wird es von der Presse
weiterhin so verbreitet als wäre es ein
wissenschaftlich bewiesener Fakt es ist
also eigentlich kein großes Wunder dass
das Verhältnis zwischen Wissenschaft und
Medien fast weltweit als unbefriedigend
empfunden wird und das ist furchtbar
schade wenn nicht sogar ein riesiges
Problem was nehmen wir jetzt also daraus
mit es ist wichtig einen kritischen
Blick auf journalistische Arbeit zu
haben man sollte nicht einfach jeder
Schlagzeile blind vertrauen am besten
wäre es natürlich selbst noch mal alle
Quellen zu überprüfen aber natürlich hat
dafür nicht jeder die Zeit und
eigentlich ist das auch nicht unser Job
wir haben hier also wirklich ein Problem
wenn wir nicht wollen dass bald niemand
mehr den Medien vertraut aber
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich gar nicht
die Medien als Einheit sondern ganz
viele unterschiedliche Häuser mit
unterschiedlichen
Qualitätsstandards ich persönlich
versuche meine Nachrichten nur von
qualitativ hochwertigen Medien zu
bekommen aber natürlich machen auch die
Fehler und haben ihre biises deswegen
gilt weiterhin Augen auf kritisch sein
und dr Watson Videos gucken denn hier
gibt's auf jeden Fall gut recherchierte
Videos über Wissenschaft und wenn ihr
hier von Fans seid dann habe ich jetzt
eine spannende Empfehlung für euch denn
der Sponsor dieses Videos ist die plusmt
Talentförderung das ist ein
Förderprogramm für junge Menschen mit
besonderem Interesse und besonderen
Fähigkeiten im mintbereich wenn ihr also
Stärken in Mathematik Informatik
Biologie Chemie Physik oder Technik habt
und diese gerne ausbauen wollt dann sind
die plus min Internate genau das
Richtige für euch an den Internaten habt
ihr einen geregelten Tagesablauf mit
Fokus auf euer Spezialgebiet im
mintbereich ihr könnt viel mehr forschen
und euch mit Wissenschaft
auseinandersetzen als bisher und habt
abends auch noch die Möglichkeit mit
Freunden Sport zu treiben oder andere
AGs wie Robotik Segeln oder Magic the
Gathering zu machen bewerben können sich
Schülerinnen und Schüler die jetzt in
der achten oder neunten Klasse sind und
sich durch besondere Leistungen z.B bei
jugendforscht den scienceolympiaden den
Mathe Känguru oder anderen Wettbewerben
hervorgetan haben und natürlich auch
schulisch besonders gut sind die
Bewerbungsphase ist heute gestartet und
geht noch bis zum 31 januar des
kommenden Jahres falls eure Neugier
jetzt geweckt ist dann schaut doch mal
über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung unten vorbei auf
plusminusmint.de ich kann es Euch
persönlich nach bestem Wissen und
Gewissen empfehlen denn ich habe
inzwischen mehrere Internate besucht und
war jedes Mal beeindruckt meine Besuche
haben wir natürlich auch gefilmt diese
Videos könnt ihr euch jetzt hier
anschauen und es kommen auch bald noch
mehr auf dem YouTube-Kanal von plusm
also auch hier abonnieren und ansonsten
wie immer vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig
reck